[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre pour ce dernier
hebdo de l'année à 2018 nous sommes le
21 décembre
voici l les principaux titres elle les
élus de saint quentin se réunissait
jeudi soir pour un conseil en grande
partie consacrée au budget 2010 9 un
budget marqué par de fortes économies
les nouvelles règles fiscales entraînant
une perte de 17 millions d'euros sur
quatre ans retour sur des débats parfois
houleux
elle nous reviendrons aussi comme chaque
vendredi sur l'essentiel de la semaine
les actualités marquantes du département
sur le plan économique notamment avec
l'inauguration du nouveau à data center
du groupe atos aux clayes-sous-bois et
puis enfin d'édition l'actualité en
ile-de-france avec nos confrères de via
grand paris et si l'acte 6d gilet jaune
se déroulait à versailles ce samedi 22
décembre c'est en tout cas à l'appel qui
a été lancé via facebook un possible
rassemblement qui amène la préfecture
réagir de 7 heures à 18 heures est cette
dernière à ce vendredi matin présenter
des mesures l'avenue de paris ne sera
pas accessible en raison de présence
probable de manifestants la circulation
rue des états généraux sera
partiellement dévié du côté des
fermetures le château de versailles la
salle du jeu de paume et les offices de
tourisme seront donc fermées à les
marchés et les animations sont maintenus
c'est un dispositif qui permet à la
manifestation de se dérouler
essentiellement dans l'avenue de paris
qui est une très large avenue plus large
que les champs elysées à paris et dans
une zone d'un périmètre défini de vent
entre la mairie et la préfecture pour
faire court mais pas devant le château
immédiatement la manifestation sera
autorisé bien entendu encadré ailleurs
non les manifestants quelles que soient
leurs intentions ne pourrons pas
manifester est perturbé en quelque sorte
les courses de noël la vie normale des
commerces et du côté des transports pour
la gare à versailles arrive gauche
château avec le rer c dans le sens paris
versailles et station viroflay rive
gauche porchefontaine versailles fermé
pour versailles rive droite circulation
interrompue entre saint cloud et
versailles a dans les deux sens le
trafic est maintenu mais sur la gare de
versailles chantiers le budget de saint
quentin en yvelines a donc été votée
jeudi soir pour 2019 le mot d'ordre est
aux économies qu'elles ont été les
arbitrages des élus retour sur une
longue soirée de discussion entre les
élus le dernier conseil d'agglomération
pour 2018 et en point d'orgue le vote du
budget pour 2010 9 jean michel fourgous
bonsoir vous venez de procéder au vote
du budget avec les élus de
l'agglomération un budget marqué par de
fortes économies 17 millions sur quatre
ans 3 millions 6 dès cette année il a
fallu faire des choix sur quoi ont porté
vos choix et bien de garde est
l'investissement donc continuer à
augmenter la partie investissement de
continuer à baisser la dette aussi ce
qui est quand même assez difficile
puisqu'on en est à plus de 80 millions
aujourd'hui
donc de réduction de dette ce qui fait
qu'on remonte notre note qui nous
permettent de faire baisser les taux
elle de nos emprunts va vous connaissez
la règle donc c'est vraiment dans le bon
sens d'une bonne gestion c'est augmenter
le bien sûr l'investissement de laisser
la dette
le fonctionnement bien sûr on l'a
légèrement modérée et c'est aussi ça va
dans le bon sens parce que c'est pas le
moment d'en inventer de nouvelles
dépenses publiques vous l'avez vu ce
soir un débat
quelqu'un qui écrit de nouvelles
dépenses publiques dont ben il ya eu un
vote négatif clair donc on a des jeux
puisque ce fameux souillon qu' il ya un
an tu un deuxième produit leur canal +
qui marche très bien
donc à saint-quentin voilà donc ça
montre bien qu'un esprit de
responsabilité de 106 me dit aujourd'hui
il faut rationaliser le plus possible
des dépenses publiques et puis surtout
garder ce cette relation avec
l'entreprise de qualité de confiance les
aider les accompagner leur simplifier la
vie pour qu'ils créent des emplois pour
qu'ils augmentent leur chiffre
d'affaires pour que ils augmentent leurs
activités économiques qui créent des
emplois qui fait rentrer de nouvelles
recettes fiscales et sociales que qui
bénéficie bien sûr à tout le monde dont
bien sûr dont 51 nourrit cette relation
très forte avec avec le monde de
l'entreprise on n'a pas augmenté les
impôts et on baisse la dette on augmente
l'investissement s'est tous les
symptômes d'une bonne gestion le
développement économiques pour s'assurer
de rentrées financières avec le
désengagement de l'état vous avez évoqué
précédemment aussi un tsunami financier
avec ce désengagement de l'état il faut
ce développement économique faire venir
des grands groupes
oui la meilleure
thérapie entre guillemets pour peau de
deux ans était quasi enfin cette chute
beau cette brutalité de baisse des
dotations pour toutes les communes de
france un bon mais la seule réponse et
surtout quand on est à 50 ans avec les
avec la qualité du débit vie divine
entreprises que nous avons très innovant
très très high tech très bien sûr que
c'est la meilleure réponse on l'a vu
d'ailleurs en est en fait cet effort
aussi exempt reprise on a fait monter le
développement économique et qui nous
permet de diminuer la douleur à ce que
la douleur c'est quand on baise on doit
baisser de 4 millions encore bon bah
c'est sûr qu'on va baisser de 2 millions
parce que parce que parce que le
développement économique a eu de très
bons résultats
donc oui c'est toute une culture tout un
état d'esprit ici c'est ce qu'on
développe vous l'avez vu d'ailleurs vous
verrez les mentalités évoluent la
majorité des gens qui dirige ici sont
des gens de l'entreprise et et moi je
souhaite qu'il y ait une culture
aujourd'hui un élu ne peut plus ne peut
plus arbitrer s'il a pas de culture
économique
d'ailleurs on le voit bien que quelqu'un
capable culture juive ou le retrouver
c'est un idéologue et vous tient des
propos idéologique
aujourd'hui la france voilà qu'est ce
que ça à voir
je crois que c'est aussi un enseignement
qu'on aille ce soir c'est qu'il ya eu un
bon rassemblement et au delà vous eu des
échanges un vif arrière mais mais bon je
moi je reste très optimiste cette maison
est venu dans mon sens
dernière question justement par rapport
à ces échanges un peu vifs et ses
quelques tensions pour vous c'est la
réouverture d'une fracture gauche-droite
c'est ce que vous avez un petit peu
exprimé non monsieur you a voulu c'est
lui qui est à l origine bon kaka
voulurent clivé je suis pas certain que
tous ses collègues et les suivis dans
cette volonté de re cliver le débat
entre nous donc c'est plutôt rassurant
voyez on a on a beau y avait un petit
exercice un peu faux directs ce soir
mais je pense que ça ça je pense que la
majorité a largement et la minorité
je crois qu'ils ont envie de travailler
ensemble encore
de ce petit problème devant devant
d'édition budgétaire difficile il faut
le dire aussi
à l'origine c'est difficile le 2-2 de
baisser de 4 millions 2,4 millions les
frais de fonctionnement
bien sûr chacun a son territoire dit oui
faut pas toucher à sa fin mais alors
quand vous écoutez certains faut toucher
à rien mais bon bah non oui c'est pas
responsable de dire ça vous ne pouvez
pas dire aujourd'hui au saint quentinois
que ont ils auront le même service
public mais avec des baisses de 20%
c'est pas possible alors si on optimise
bien sûr qu'on a la chance d'avoir des
entreprises qui qui compense kickstart
mais il faut il faut pas exclure que
nous ne nommerons toute façon baisser
baisser un certain nombre de choses
voilà il faut il faut dire la vérité aux
gens qui dure il comprend un témoin les
français vous pas arrêter les ans les
prendre pour des ddd des analphabètes de
l'économie donc là ils savent aussi
dépensé acheter il va bien le prix voilà
si vous gagnez si vous gagnez sans vous
pouvez pas dépenser 120 durablement bas
et donc l'âme on vient le mans très
difficile enfin tous mes collègues
maires et patrons d'agglo sens à tout
cela on se voit et on encore lire soit
on était plusieurs à dîner ensemble et
on a tous les mêmes problèmes à deux
chiffres pour ce budget 2010 9 235
millions d'euros de dépenses de
fonctionnement 80 millions d'euros de
dépenses et d'investissements et deux
éléments pour comprendre les nécessaires
économie fiscalité plus pénalisante de
la part de l'état et diminution des
dotations il a donc fallu repenser les
dépenses concernant lé réseau
d'éclairage public les voiries ou encore
les espaces verts et une partie de la
politique de la ville et vous l'avez
compris les arbitrages n'ont pas fait
l'unanimité
lors des débats les quatre communes
gérées par la gauche magny les hameaux
la verrière trappe aiguille en cours
évoque de mauvaises priorités
les maires de ces quatre communes ont
également distribué un courrier à leurs
administrés quelques jours avant le
conseil courrier peu apprécié par la
majorité qui a dénoncé à de fausses
informations et la mise en avant de
pistes d'économies non retenus où on a
estimé ce que j'ai dit en intervenant
publiquement tout à l'heure que il
fallait il fallait d'abord préserver
tout ce qui
il sert le quotidien c'est une formule 1
cd tout ce qui sert le quotidien des
habitants et donc un ad budget culture
religieuse associatif qui baisse et donc
on pouvait sans doute trouver les 3
millions 6 ailleurs exemples concrets
samedi à les ferries de trappes c'est
ouvert à tout le monde aux enfants aux
familles etc et et et je ne fais pas de
cérémonie de voeux
parce que ben il faut faire un choix
budgétaires les deux ça passait pas on a
choisi celui qui est auprès des
habitants donc voilà c'est tout mais ça
ne vont pas d'aidé du kurel le
simplement il est normal que les choix
soit affirmée et dit aux habitants le
département des yvelines présenté
également son budget ce vendredi matin
l'an prochain ce budget se chiffre à un
milliard cinq à retenir pas
d'augmentation d'impôts des dépenses de
fonctionnement contenu un niveau
d'investissement maintenu la
collectivité devrait investir 420
millions d'euros en 2019 a
principalement dans la modernisation des
mobilités le développement du territoire
mais aussi pour les collèges écouter ses
propos accueillis par grégory canal est
avec un état totalement epec mieux et
qui passe son temps à faire les poches
des collectivités en particulier des
départements
il fallait que nous tenons notre cap de
bonne gestion faibles dépenses de
fonctionnement c'est-à-dire la vie
quotidienne on est le département de
france qui dépensent le moins en
dépenses de fonctionnement
c'est un record d'autre part stabilité
fiscale
donc on fait pas appel au portefeuille
des contribuables donc ces dépenses là
c'est des dépenses dans les équipements
des dépenses dans les infrastructures de
transport c'est pour améliorer la vie
quotidienne de nos concitoyens
[Musique]
il
nous passons donc au résumé de cette
semaine avec tout d'abord la
contestation des gilet jaune qui s'est
poursuivie aussi dans le département
notamment à coignières après avoir été
délogés par les forces de l'ordre en fin
de semaine dernière les manifestants
sont revenus et quelques personnes
toujours mobilisés car non satisfaites
par les dernières annonces du
gouvernement sur l'augmentation du smic
via la prime d'activité la réflexion
promise aussi sur le rics référendum
d'initiative citoyenne
autre actualité également voilà pour
cette contestation qui se poursuivent
autre actualité de la semaine sur saint
quentin en yvelines également la
signature d'un plan entre
l'agglomération et le département pour
accélérer la rénovation urbaine de huit
quartiers prioritaires précision mélanie
poker c'est une signature à 15 millions
d'euros
cette convention entre le département
des yvelines et l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines porte sur la
rénovation urbaine c'est pas une commune
aujourd'hui qui peut faire face bien sûr
à de tels engagements
donc heureusement le département des
yvelines vient
bien sûr nous nous accompagner nous
soutenir et puis effectivement déclenché
avec ses moyens
ces opérations de rénovation dont on a
terriblement besoin dans ces quartiers
là le département veut poursuivre ce que
l'état ne fait plus l'état à
l'initiative de jean louis borloo alors
ministre d'état ministre de la ville
s'était engagée dans le renouvellement
urbain petit à petit on voit que ce qui
a été fait se dégrade et l'impatience de
ceux pour qui rien n'est fait et le
risque c'est qu'on retombe dans cette
spirale vicieuse et négatives
restructuration de gymnase
réhabilitation des espaces publics
ces opérations ont été recensés pour
cette commune et huit quartiers dont
deux à trappes
nous ça nous permet d'intervenir sur des
opérations dès maintenant et ça permet
aussi aux bailleurs d'intervenir sur
quelques opérations avaient aidé des
subventionnements élevé puisque ça
atteint 70% du montant des travaux dans
un cadre de cinq millions d'euros pour
la ville de trappes
ça concerne nous surtout
d'agrandissement d'écoles ou des
aménagements autour des cols parce que
c'est toujours la con qu'on veut
travailler en priorité puis ça concerne
pergaud debussy et védrine en ce qui
concerne les lieux d'habitat la
rénovation urbaine sur saint quentin en
yvelines est évalué à plus de 37
millions d'euros
les projets doivent être lancés avant le
31 décembre 2019 le département
décidément actifs cette semaine avec
également des engagements avec la
communauté d'agglomération saint germain
boucles de seine et la ville du pecq
afin d'aider les communes déficitaires
en logements sociaux marie-hélène
iapichino une enveloppe de 10 7 millions
d'euros pour soutenir la construction de
logements sociaux sur la ville du pecq à
commune et le département signé ce
mercredi 19 décembre une convention en
ce sens la ville va pouvoir accueillir
une trentaine de familles
supplémentaires dans un ancien foyer
étudiant ça a été difficile
ce que vous imaginez que c'est quand
même pas simple quand hier 27
c'était voilà ça a été assez compliqué
mais c'est quand même incroyable parce
que ce soir on a signé et en allant on a
réussi à boucler ce projet est la ville
du bec a donc aujourd'hui + 24 % de
logements sociaux ont pour nous c'est
vraiment formidable
le pecs n'est pas un cas isolé 19 autres
communes du département sont carencés
pour non respect de leurs objectifs en
termes de logements sociaux
le département voudrait les aider vous
imaginez donc bien que si les communes
n'arrive pas à suivre
ça devient très vite une contrainte
quasi impossible à réduire et sa des
conséquences très graves pour les
habitants parce qu'il y à des amendes
financières prévues sur le budget de
l'état
tout s'accumule effet que c'est très
défavorable aux libertés communales est
très défavorable à la qualité de vie
dans les communes selon le département
un quart des vies les yvelinoises
doivent atteindre l'objectif des 25 % de
logements sociaux dans les prochaines
années
le nouveau data center d'atos inauguré
mardi sur le site des clayes-sous-bois
une infrastructure pour héberger
protéger des données informatiques des
clients du groupe un outil stratégique
dans l'activité de cybersécurité pour
cette entreprise basée à saint quentin
en yvelines
des armoires prête à accueillir des
serveurs informatiques c'est un
datacenter la nouvelle infrastructure du
groupe atos dans son activité de cyber
sécurité
quelques semaines après avoir posé la
première pierre de son futur centre de
recherche et développement
alors vous êtes dans le module 2 seule
différence ce sont les couleurs
le but de tout ça c'est se repérer dans
l'espace parle par le biais par le biais
des couleurs caractéristiques de ce data
center sa modularité aujourd'hui de
modules sont opérationnels soit 1300 m²
à terme 8 modules composeront
l'établissement sur un espace de 8000 m²
objectif renouveler les datacenter
existant sur les normes
environnementales et les capacités
informatiques les clés ce site c'est
vraiment un site qui est au coeur de
notre stratégie d'investissement pour
nos clients
externe à travers les data center mais
également pour nous mêmes pour pouvoir
avec nos ingénieurs de haute renommée
développer des ordinateurs de très
hautes performances quantique des
algorithmes quantique pour de bas et
également tous des produits de
cybersécurité le département des
yvelines a accompagné atos hauteur de
5,5 millions d'euros à travers une aide
à l'innovation est l'acquisition
foncière d'un terrain pour le mettre à
disposition aider les entreprises à
créer de la richesse c'est la seule
façon de faire depuis 100 ans ensuite
avoir des politiques sociales
redistributive
les premiers clients d'atos installeront
leurs serveurs en janvier 2019 des
partenaires du secteur de la santé de la
défense ou encore de la distribution
dans l'actualité locale à voisins le
bretonneux les tensions perdurent tour
de la question de la circulation en
cause les aménagements prévus dans les
communes alentour et les réponses
apportées par l'équipe municipale manon
varaldo pour ce reportage
un projet qui fait débat dans le cadre
de l'aménagement du futur quartier la
gare de la ligne 18 50 ans est un
dévoiement de l'ère des 91 est prévu
cette départementale fait la jonction
entre versailles et la vallée de
chevreuse en traversant guyancourt et
voisins le bretonneux
cette déviation s'effectuera en deux
fois deux voies en prolongement de
l'avenue de l'europe la route arriverait
alors depuis guyancourt et le
technocentre renault directement sur le
quartier de la bretonnière de
voisins-le-bretonneux les membres de
l'adav association de défense des
habitants de la ville vicinaux aux
redoute les conséquences de ce projet on
imagine plus de circulation qui sera
très important avec un tourne à gauche à
hauteur du campanile alors
qu'aujourd'hui cet axe de la d81 venant
de versailles
la minière et à lanvallay vers la vallée
de chevreuse travers directement le
carrefour ces modifications de
circulation s'accompagne de la
construction de 1300 logements d'ici
2030 sur l'ancien site de l'entreprise
thalès plus un parking de 800 places un
parking relais pour les gens
ils fréquenteront la ligne de métro mais
imaginez qu'il a à peu près de 4000
personnes soit un tiers de la population
de voisins qui vont évoluer dans ce
quartier où convergeait vers ce quartier
donc un tiers de la population de
voisins sur un terrain qui fait 20
hectares un dixième de la surface de
voisins-le-bretonneux on imagine des
conséquences que ça aura l'adav défend
le contournement sud de
voisins-le-bretonneux qui était prévu à
l'origine de la ville nouvelle
contacté par notre rédaction la mère de
voisins-le-bretonneux alexandra rosetti
n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer sur le sujet
c'est une première à guyancourt une
patinoire géante installée à l'intérieur
du pavillon waldeck-rousseau enfants et
grands enfants pour en profiter jusqu'au
31 décembre près de 162 mètres carrés
pour à s'adonner aux joies de la glisse
le synthétique a été tout de même
préféré à la glace pour des raisons
d'économie d'énergie mais le plaisir est
toujours au rendez vous c'est super
parce que on gardait des dessins animés
avec nos filles qui se passait dehors
des patinoires et comme ça on pourrait
les emmener perdure est patent
[Musique]
l'actualité en ile-de-france à présent
avec nos confrères de via grand paris et
après les grandes crues en janvier
dernier en juin et 2016 la ratp veut
améliorer son dispositif la moitié du
métro parisien se trouve en zone
inondable comment se prépare
l'entreprise éléments de réponse avec ce
reportage
10h30 du matin sur le parvis de la
station balard dans le xvème
arrondissement
ces agents de la ratp construit un
barrage en aluminium objectif protéger
cette grille de désenfumage pour
empêcher l'eau de s'infiltrer en cas
d'inondation c'est facile de montage qui
va beaucoup moins de monde on arrive à
faire la même chose
un édifice dé tous donc
gain de temps énorme après les grandes
crues en janvier 2018 et juin 2016
la ratp veut améliorer son dispositif la
moitié du métro parisien se trouve en
zone inondable la régie des transports
parisiens anticipe le pire
ce matin c'est le scénario d'une crue
centennale qui est envisagée en 1910 la
scène était monté de plus de 8 mètres
les six agents mettront trois heures
pour protéger cette installation
on vient mettre en place d édification
dans le 15e arrondissement qui vont
venir protéger les infrastructures du
risque dans nos moments et s'assurer
qu'en fait qu'on soit en capacité
après une crue centennale de reprendre
l'exploitation rapidement et par
ailleurs d'être en mesure de continuer
l'exploitation le plus longtemps
possible dans des conditions de sécurité
optimales l'exercice de simulation se
déroule aussi de l'autre côté de la rue
ici on teste l'ancienne méthode un muret
en béton pour imperméabiliser cette
grille d'aération la structure demande
plus de moyens mais surtout de temps ils
sont huit agents pour 8 heures demain 2
on suit les plans qui ne sont qui sont
dédiés on vérifie pas l'étanchéité parce
qu'il faudrait mettre
de l'eau et ça ne peut pas le faire mais
on sait qu'en mettant ce genre de
parpaings en ce sens avec
couler du ciment au milieu hydrofuge on
sait qu'on va pouvoir tenir la hauteur
d'eau qui est prévu alors on se fie à la
crue de 1910 pour savoir quelle
structure on doit pouvoir monter à 13 ou
tel endroit
la ratp peut aujourd'hui mobiliser 1000
personnes pour réagir en cas de crue
majeure 400 points d'entrée ont été
identifiés sur le réseau quelques images
à présent avant de se quitter de notre
rendez vous spécial fêtes de fin d'année
la rédaction vous a préparé plus d'une
heure d'émission pour vous accompagner
pendant les prochains jours du champ à
des cadeaux des idées sorties quelques
paires par an performance pardon
sportive aussi et puis également à dylan
l'un des membres des kids united
originaire des yvelines qui est venu sur
ce plateau ce sera à découvrir à compter
du 24 décembre
c'est la fin de ce s est 8m de haut je
vous souhaite au nom de tv 78 excellent
réveillon on se retrouve à compter du 2
janvier à 18h en direct pour le journal
présenté par grégory canale et d'ici là
n'oubliez pas tout nous replay sur notre
site internet et notre application
mobile
[Musique]